c'est parti c'est une phrase d'Élisabeth
borne qui a relancé la bataille
politique autour de l'examen de la
proposition de loi du groupe pilote à
l'Assemblée nationale qui vise à abroger
la réforme des retraites alors le débat
aura t-il lieu c'est la question on voit
ça et Quentin calmé
Matignon mercredi soir et Isabelle vient
de terminer son cycle de rencontre avec
les syndicats mais sur le perron un
sujet revient celui de l'examen le 8
juin de la proposition de loi liotte qui
vise à abroger la réforme des retraites
Elizabeth borne sagace et dénonce le
texte il est assez irresponsable de la
part d'un groupe parlementaire de
laisser croire qu'on peut présenter une
proposition de loi qui supprime 18
milliards de ressources et que cette
proposition de loi pourrait prospérer
cette proposition d'abrogation est un
constitutionnel je pense qu'il faut que
chacun soit conscient et que chacun
prenne ses responsabilités en
conséquence cette petite phrase fait
réagir depuis mercredi soir notamment
les syndicats qui tous soutiennent la
proposition de loi hier dans le JDD
Laurent Berger de la CFDT dit à avoir
alerté l'exécutif en lui demandant je
cite de ne pas recourir un subterfuge
pour empêcher l'examen de la proposition
de loi du groupe IUT le 8 juin le
ressentiment est trop fort dans le pays
dit-il mais dans la majorité on assume
vouloir empêcher l'examen d'un texte non
financé nous considérons que cette loi
n'est pas dans les clous de la
Constitution quand débattre ces mentir
aux Français
de bloquer la discussion s'il existe des
moyens il existe des moyens et nous
aurons d'abord l'occasion de débattre en
commission des affaires sociales de
cette loi nous verrons les choses en
séance à gauche la France insoumise
fourbit ses armes avant l'examen du 8
juin ce matin sur notre antenne le
président de la commission des finances
de l'Assemblée nationale Lassure
l'examen du texte ira au bout voilà je
crois que ce gouvernement n'en sera de
ce point de vue là qu'au début de ses
problèmes et je lui répète je pense que
il ferait bien enfin de comprendre que
sur cette propulsion loi il est archi
minoritaire dans le pays et qu'il est
très certainement minoritaire à
l'Assemblée nationale mais qu'il le
laisse vérifier le 8 c'est ça que je
demande d'accord puisqu'il a l'air de
dire que ça ne se réglera rien c'est pas
très grave mais qu'il le laisse vérifier
au moins respirable mieux prochaine
étape fin mai avec l'examen de cette
proposition de loi en commission à
l'Assemblée nationale
on voit un la bataille politique qui
s'annoncer 15 prochains jours arrivent
est-ce que Elisabeth borne a eu tort de
dire à ce moment-là que le texte était
inconstitutionnel oui sans doute elle a
elle a tout de suite je dirais
donner ses arguments et montrer et
donner à avoir ces sa contre-offensive
si vous voulez c'est dommage elle a pour
elle elle sait privée d'une arme qu'elle
aurait peut-être eu donc elle aurait
peut-être eu besoin le jour J elle
aurait pas fait monter l'attention et là
le problème elle l'a fait que faire
monter la tension et je trouve que c'est
assez maladroit parce qu'on est dans une
période justement où le gouvernement la
première ministre devrait essayer de
d'apaiser les choses et elle aurait dû
dégainer au dernier moment si on avait
besoin dans la mesure où de toute
manière il faut pas l'oublier
la loi est passée avec neuf voix d'écart
pourquoi ne pas essayer de tenter le
même coup cette fois-ci
sachant que c'est pas le même on l'a dit
souvent sur ce plateau mais c'est pas le
même mode de vote une motion de censure
et une proposition de la
majorité absolue des députés pour voter
votre notion donc les abstentions
comptent entre guillemets pour le
gouvernement là on a affaire un texte
ordinaire donc ce faisant si tout le
monde n'est pas là et si vous avez une
participation différentielle des députés
de la majorité le gouvernement est dans
la panade parce que si beaucoup de
députés traînent les pieds pour venir
voter ce texte alors que la nuque et le
RN et ben probablement mobiliseront
leurs troupes et ben évidemment ça veut
dire que vous pouvez être théoriquement
majoritaire mais pratiquement au moment
du vote minoritaire et à ce moment-là
les lois de l'arithmétique sont
implacables alors
Elisabeth bande de dire que c'était un
const exceptionnel est-ce que
juridiquement Benjamin escala raison
est-ce que ce texte est un
constitutionnel si vous voulez c'est
très hypocrite l'article 40 c'est à dire
qu'est-ce qui se passe d'habitude étant
donné que en deux mots qu'est-ce que
c'est l'article 40 tout le monde
commence à le savoir mais c'est les
irrecevabilités financières donc votre
proposition de loi ne doit pas entraîner
de charges supplémentaires pour l'État
qu'est-ce qu'on fait d'habitude bah
lorsqu'on veut quand même faire une
proposition de loi qui a un coup et ben
on va la gager on va trouver une source
qui va être une source dynamique de
financement qui va permettre
d'équilibrer les comptes ces gages en
règle générale sont très hypocrites et
donc en effet si vous considérez
l'hypocrisie de gâcher une réforme des
retraites sur la réforme du tabac oui
c'est évidemment plutôt un
constitutionnel en même temps on le fait
tout le temps et en même temps très
souvent la présidence de la commission
des finances la Présidence de
l'Assemblée le gouvernement font comme
si c'était suffisant parce que notamment
quand le texte n'a pas pour but d'être
adopté une fine de devenir réellement
loin on considère que on a le droit de
débattre et que donc ce faisant l'Artic
transparente ne doit pas représenter un
obstacle au débat et donc on fait comme
si et là on pourrait comme on le fait
d'habitude faire comme si donc il y a
beaucoup d'hypocrisie de la part de
l'opposition de dire mais si c'est
évidemment sur le tabac c'est gagé il y
a pas de problème et il y a beaucoup
d'hypocrisie du gouvernement de dire
mais attendez c'est une horreur c'est
inconstitutionnelle c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'un femme c'est une
atteinte à la démocratie alors qu'on le
fait tout le temps et que la plupart du
temps bah Elisabeth borne n'en dit rien
de toute façon dans cette affaire de la
réforme des retraites il y a une forme
d'hypocrisie juridique depuis le début
on peut rappeler aussi l'épisode de
l'utilisation d'un budget rectificatif
de la sécurité sociale par le
gouvernement là à ce moment-là et bien
c'est l'opposition qui disait que
c'était et bien inconstitutionnel
hypocrite hypocrite parce que l'objectif
final du gouvernement c'était de pouvoir
utiliser un 49-3 ce qui était possible
avec cette procédure et puis aussi de
limiter le temps des débats ce qui a été
fait par le gouvernement et on le
rappelle au final le Conseil
constitutionnel à juger et bien valide à
cette procédure
quel est l'intérêt de la majorité dans
cette histoire est-ce qu'il a intérêt à
laisser le débat aller jusqu'au bout
quitte est-ce que l'Assemblée nationale
vote le texte ou est-ce qu'il intéresse
à couper court au débat pour qu'il n'y
ait pas de vote non moi j'aurais plutôt
tendance à penser que il a intérêt à
laisser le débat s'installer et puis
aller jusqu'au bout parce que
le gouvernement c'est pas un secret il
est très impopulaire l'exécutif est très
un peu populaire il est on est dans une
période extrêmement tendue on a rarement
vu autant d'attaque contre l'exécutif
que aujourd'hui de façon aussi violente
et moi je crois qu'il ferait une grosse
une grosse faute politique en ne
laissant pas le débat
continuer
il va y avoir la manifestation du 6 du 6
juin et après il va y avoir le vote du 8
juin est-ce que là il a intérêt à
dégainer l'article 40
c'est pas certain moi je pense que si il
arrive à mobiliser dans son camp et
qu'il arrive à faire en sorte que tout
le monde soit là ça peut peut-être ça
peut peut-être marcher je crois qu'il
aurait intérêt à ce à jouer comme ça
plutôt qu'à essayer de sortir une arme
qui serait une arme peut-être alors
nucléaire et qui mettrait encore tout le
monde dans la rue et je crois qu'il a
intérêt à ce que les choses aillent
jusqu'au bout Benjamin
en réalité c'est extrêmement compliqué
parce que pour le gouvernement il y a
que des mauvaises solutions soit vous
essayez de dégainer article 40 ce qui
est compliqué parce que il vous a pas
échappé ce matin car il Coquerel n'était
pas son plus chaud partisan ou bien vous
essayez de faire de l'obstruction pour
qu'on examine pas dans le temps de la
niche et bien ce texte mais évidemment
ensuite aller dire que la fi nuit à la
démocratie en faisant de l'obstruction
parce que tout le monde sait depuis les
années 80 bah ça devient plus compliqué
comme narratif ou bien en effet vous
acceptez de potentiellement perdre et là
je pourrais être d'accord avec qui avec
une limite tout de même c'est que
mobiliser dans le camp de la majorité
aujourd'hui est très compliqué non
seulement la majorité relative mais
l'exposé façon puzzle donc si jamais
vous donnez comme image et bien une
majorité en capillotade c'est
extrêmement cruel et très très difficile
à gérer pour la suite alors il sera
toujours possible de dire en fait les
méchants c'est le Sénat parce que vous
comprenez ils ont voté contre cette
merveilleuse proposition de loi donc
entre guillemets faire porter le chapeau
au Palais du Luxembourg c'est un grand
grand classique mais malgré tout pour la
majorité même si infini le texte
n'arrivera pas au bout et ben ce sera un
constat extrêmement cruel de se voir
minoritaire et qui plus est divisé parce
que pour qu'on comprenne bien même si le
8 juin l'Assemblée nationale vote ce
texte il y a peu de chances qu'au final
le parcours parlementaire fasse que
c'est que ça arrive au bout bah le texte
arrivera probablement au Sénat alors
après qu'un groupe le reprenne dans sa
niche mais a priori c'est quand même
très très probable il faut trouver une
majorité au Sénat or il vous a pas
échappé que le Sénat n'était pas tout à
fait le même couleur politique que
l'Assemblée nationale donc à ce stade il
est assez peu probable que la
proposition de loi arrive au Sénat
ensuite il y a deux possibilités soit le
gouvernement décide de réunir une
commission mixte paritaire ou les deux
présidents des deux chambres c'est très
peu probable soit le texte est mis de
côté il peut être pris dans une autre
niche parlementaire à l'Assemblée
nationale même rejeté au Sénat mais ça
changera pas fondamentalement la donne
ça serait un peu la torture sur le temps
long pour le gouvernement parce qu'il
pourrait être réadopter à l'Assemblée il
reviendrait dans le même état au Sénat
qui probablement le rejeter très encore
donc ça peut être une sorte de fil rouge
de sparadrap le capitaine Haddock du
quinquennat avec un texte qui revient de
manière je dirais épisodique après avoir
été rejeté au Sénat mais évidemment le
texte infini adopté ça nécessiterait
soit que le schéma le Sénat change
d'avis considérant que oui le texte il
faut le voter soit que l'isabeth borne
dise je vais soumettre le texte au
dernier mot à l'Assemblée nationale ce
qui est évidemment apparaît fort
improbable et totalement kamikaze et
c'est ce que laisse entendre certains je
pense à Fabien Roussel à Laurent Berger
hier dans le Journal du Dimanche que
finalement ce texte est bien à deux
grandes chances de ne pas arriver au
bout même s'ils demandent à l'Assemblée
le débat et le vote
effectivement c'est le pourrissement qui
vont qui vont essayer jouer moi je suis
assez d'accord avec Benjamin et donc on
verra mais je crois que il faut pas que
préalablement le gouvernement fasse de
l'obstruction parce que ça peut nuire
aussi ce qui est aussi un peu dérangé
les syndicats c'est qu'elle a fait cette
déclaration à l'issue des concertations
des syndicales
sur un plan politique c'est pas habile
du tout parce que vous fermez le jeu
alors que justement tout ce qui est
reprochait aujourd'hui au gouvernement
actuellement c'est de fermer le jeu donc
elle avait au plus tôt intérêt à ouvrir
le jeu alors qu'elle était justement
dans une disposition de dialogue avec
les syndicats donc là elle a fait une
erreur psychologique à mon avis et ça va
nuire au dialogue social qui est en
train timidement de reprendre Benjamin
ça va pas aider mais il est vrai que
jusqu'au 8 de toute façon il va être
compliqué pour les syndicats de dire
qu'il passe à autre chose et si jamais
la proposition loi en y revient est
adopté le 8 ça veut dire que une finale
aura une nouvelle date la date de
l'examen au Sénat et il y a probablement
un groupe très rapidement de
l'opposition qui va inscrire la
proposition de loi à son agenda et donc
ce faisant ça va encore reporter
redonner à de l'espoir mais en tout cas
une date butoir au syndicat donc pour le
gouvernement c'est extrêmement compliqué
d'où la peut-être la volonté également
de couper court à cette affaire si c'est
rejeté à l'Assemblée et bien il y a plus
réellement de nouvelles dates a priori
dans le processus législatif Marc et
retraite pour l'instant et donc ce
faisant ça peut permettre de tourner la
page mais évidemment ça implique de se
mettre encore un peu plus adoles
syndicats ce dont l'exécutif n'a guère
besoin qu'elle peut être l'attitude des
républicains le 8 juin il est ce que ce
sera le même schéma que lors du vote de
la motion de censure où est-ce qu'on
entend certains opposants à la réforme
des retraites être un peu gênée par le
fait que la CGT s'affiche avec le groupe
les hot
si on écoute les députés qui ont voté
contre la réforme dans au sein des LR
ils sont sur autant et ce sont les mêmes
ils ont affiché leur détermination
Pradier
Aurélien Pradier en tête à tel point que
justement chez les LR il y a une
interrogation qui se pose est-ce qu'ils
vont pas faire jouer carrément le coup
près et puis si jamais il continue comme
ça se séparer de de dissidents donc à
mon avis il est LR ils sont dans la même
disposition enfin dans la même
dans le même état d'esprit divisé est-ce
qu'ils essayent de surmonter justement
par leur proposition sur l'immigration
où là ils affichent un front uni et on
va en parler justement les républicains
qui ont donc présenté hier uni leurs
proposition de loi sur l'immigration
dans le Journal du dimanche ils veulent
durcir drastiquement la politique
migratoire Alex effectivement Oriane la
républicains qui lancent un défi à
Emmanuel Macron hier en une du JDD
reprendre leur mesure pour réguler
l'immigration le président du parti
irisottile président du groupe à
l'Assemblée nationale Olivier Marleix
c'est le président du groupe LR au Sénat
Bruno retaillod on présenté ce plan
immigration DLR un plan en deux volets
avec d'abord une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle un texte qui propose
de modifier notre Constitution pour
d'abord affirmer le refus des
communautarismes et le devoir
d'assimilation à la Communauté française
ce taxi le permet aussi d'organiser un
référendum sur tous les sujets et donc
sur l'immigration alors qu'aujourd'hui
ce n'est possible que sur certains
sujets comme l'organisation des pouvoirs
publics ou encore les réformes
économiques et sociales et puis point
très important les républicains veulent
que la France puisse déroger au traité
internationaux et aux traités européens
pour
expliquer parfois certaines lois qu'il
jugeraient dans l'intérêt fondamental de
la nation le but est bien c'est de
naître plus rattrapé sur les sujets
migratoires par des décisions de la
justice européenne et puis cette
proposition loi conçu constitutionnelle
elle inscrit également dans ce texte
fondamental et bien elle est notions de
quota d'immigration et d'expulsion des
personnes qui représenteraient une
menace pour la sécurité publique et puis
les demandes d'asile se feraient hors du
territoire national dans les postes
consulaires et diplomatiques de la
France à l'étranger et à l'extérieur
républicains qui veulent mettre en
oeuvre d'autres mesures sur
l'immigration et ça c'est dans le cadre
d'une proposition de l'ordinaire oui une
proposition de Loire avec un premier
objectif pour les républicains diminuer
le nombre le nombre d'immigrés qui
arrivent chaque année en France avec ce
texte et bien le Parlement votre a tous
les ans des quotas d’immigration le
regroupement familial sera durci tout
comme le contrôle des étudiants
étrangers cette proposition de loi
ordinaire elle veut également dissuader
les candidats à l'immigration en
restignant le panier de soins de l'aide
médicale d'État pour en faire une aide
médicale d'urgence ça c'est une mesure
qui est votée par exemple chaque année
au Sénat dans le budget de la Sécurité
sociale et puis autre objectif de ce
texte est bien facilité les expulsions
le texte rétablit le délit de séjour
irréguliers supprimé sous François
Hollande ainsi que la double peine la
double peine c'est quand un étranger est
condamné purge s'appelle et est ensuite
expulsé ce qui est peu souvent le cas
depuis une vingtaine d'années et puis
les LR veulent aussi et bien délivrer
l'aide au développement et des visas à
certains pays si et seulement si c'est
même pays des livres des laissés passer
consulaires pour reprendre leur
ressortissants expulser de France et
puis enfin ce texte il rend aussi
possible la suppression du droit du sol
si les Parents étrangers d'un enfant né
en France sont en situation irrégulière
au moment de la naissance de l'enfant
donc voilà toute une batterie de mesure
et en tout cas la proposition de loi
ordinaire sera examinée au Sénat à
l'automne merci Alex Benjamin les
républicain en raison un durcissement de
la politique migratoire passe forcément
par une modification de la Constitution
alors d'un point de vue politique c'est
plutôt intelligent mais je laisserai
peut-être Yves commenter j'irai l'aspect
plutôt tactique ensuite oui c'est à dire
que vous savez beaucoup de choses qui
ont été dites par leur pendant la
campagne présidentielle notamment le
programme immigrants migratoire de
Valérie Pécresse mais pas que et ben
lorsqu'on interroge les juristes on
passait notre temps à dire c'est pas
constitutionnel et c'est important parce
que c'est également l'un des objets du
de la proposition de loi c'est pas
conventionnel c'est contraire au traité
européen que vise à faire la proposition
de loi LR mais justement à pouvoir
déroger mais là il y a deux limites
parce que la preuve vous avez une
proposition loi ordinaire qui est
conditionnée pour être applicable à la
proposition loi constitutionnelle mais
là déroger au traité européen pourquoi
pas mais ça implique de déclarer la
guerre à la CJE hein vous voyez la
Pologne en grippe les batailles qui peut
y avoir aujourd'hui au niveau européen
ça implique d'être dans cette démarche
là pourquoi pas mais il faut l'assumer
je suis pas sûr qu'aujourd'hui LR soit
dans une position
souverainiste assez dur pour assumer une
déclaration de guerre la CJE première
élément deuxième élément une proposition
de loi il faut la majorité dans les deux
chambres au Sénat ça peut passer je
doute que à l'Assemblée nationale d'une
majorité pour voter y compris une
version amendée de cette proposition loi
constitutionnelle c'est une proposition
loi constitutionnelle ça veut dire qu'il
y a pas de congrès à une Chine ça veut
dire que infini si jamais ça devait être
adopté par miracle dans les deux
chambres très peu probable et bien on
aurait un référendum déclenché par le
chef de l'État voyez-vous Emmanuel
Macron soumettre ça à référendum très
très peu probable donc on est dans des
propositions de loi d'affichage très
très clairement la probabilité que tout
ça arrive au bout est à peu près égale à
zéro après
= celle d'un sujet dont on parlait
précédemment
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça s'interroge toujours pour savoir
s'ils sont pour ou contre là c'est eux
qui prennent l'initiative deuxième chose
troisième chose
il
je dirais par rapport à la au projet de
loi du gouvernement sur l'immigration
qui est assez illisible parce que il est
dans le en même temps et que finalement
il ne plaît à personne et bien eux ils
ont une proposition de propositions qui
sont très claires même si elles sont
très radicales donc moi je pense que ce
qu'ils ont fait même si effectivement
sur un plan constitutionnel et sur un
plan purement juridique c'est pas sûr
que cette affaire et c'est même probable
que cette affaire de débouche sur rien
en termes d'affichage c'est plutôt c'est
plutôt à mon avis appelé à restaurer la
confiance qui peut exister vis-à-vis
d'eux et à certains crédits après il y a
un reproche qu'on peut leur faire mais
c'est un reproche auquel ils peuvent
vite je dirais qu'ils peuvent vite et
écartés c'est celui de dire bon Babou
sucer la roue si vous perdez
l'expression le Tour de France et non
pas longtemps
vous sucez la roue de rassemblement
national et mais bon ça me paraît quand
même pas très
les arguments favorables les arguments
favorables sont me paraissent beaucoup
plus fort
Erics dit nous on n'est pas pour
l'immigration zéro ça c'est c'est démago
comme le dit le rassemblement national
donc il essaye il se détache il essaye
déjà de se détacher un peu de cet
argument oui c'est une forme de réponse
à Gérald Darmanin parce que
souvenez-vous la polémique il y a
quelques semaines avec Georgia Meloni
qu'est-ce qu'il dit Darmanin au fond il
dit bah regardez de toute façon pouvait
tenter l'extrême droite à côté mais ça
ne changera rien parce que les cadres et
notamment conventionnels sont tellement
contraintes que et ben jordya Meloni à
peu près la même politique migratoire
que celle que nous faisons et infinie et
ben c'est pour Gérald Darmanin également
constater sa propre impuissance parce
que c'est d'y regarder en Italie elle
n'arrive pas à faire grand chose et ben
en creux moi non plus et ce que dit LR
ici c'est ben en fait nous on est
justement apte à donner les outils
juridiques pour demain à tort ou à
raison mener une politique qui soit une
politique offensive encore une fois ils
en assument pas forcément les
conséquences mais néanmoins là dessus et
bien aujourd'hui sur l'immigration comme
sur d'autres sujets la crise de la
représentation est liée souvent à une
crise de est-ce que l'État peut encore
vraiment agir est-ce que vraiment le
politique peut avoir des marges de
manœuvre sur telle ou tel sujet en
disant oui on peut on peut agir on peut
réagir en se donnant justement des
instruments et ben malgré tout vous
donner le sentiment de demain si vous
arrivez au pouvoir faire quelque chose
et ça aujourd'hui quand vous voulez
réenchanter la politique bah c'est
premier
alors pour
inspirer cette cette proposition de loi
enfin cet ensemble ce dispositif global
je pense qu'ils se sont beaucoup
inspirés de ce qui se passe au Danemark
parce que le Danemark a réussi à
juguler une immigration qui jugeait trop
forte proportionnellement alors
population ils se sont affranchis des
traités internationaux mais dans une
condition dans un contexte très très
particulier c'était après le vote sur le
traité de Maastricht qu'ils ont refusé
dans un premier temps et en refusant le
traité de Maastricht parce que justement
il y avait des mesures qui leur
déplaisaient sur le front migratoire et
bien ils ont réussi à trouver des
aménagements vis-à-vis de Bruxelles et
c'est un peu dans cet esprit là que
pense travailler les républicains mais
bon est-ce que c'est possible maintenant
dans le contexte actuel je sais pas si
on se demandait aussi si la stratégie
des républicains finalement ce n'est pas
d'obtenir l'échec du projet loi
immigration du gouvernement en tout cas
voilà là officiellement
parce que en même temps les républicains
s'ils veulent faire passer leur texte à
l'Assemblée Benjamin a dit ils ont
besoin de la majorité et la majorité si
elles veulent faire passer son patron
du tout puisque
la réponse est non en réalité il y a pas
de points d'équilibre et d'ailleurs
Olivier Marleix dans l'interview dans le
JDD a dit que si jamais le projet loi
immigration de gel le Dardan n'était pas
assez radicale ne reprenait pas assez
les mesures des républicains et bien un
les républicains ne voteraient pas et
deux il pourrait y avoir une motion de
censure proposée par les LR et alors là
une motion de censure avec une signature
LR ça peut rassembler ça peut faire
mouche sauf que vous avez eu la réponse
d'Eric Coquerel tout à l'heure qui a dit
qu'il était hors de question qui vote
une notion de censure sur ce sujet là
par des républicains pour le bon unique
raison c'est qu'ils peuvent pas
s'associer ou associer leur parti
politique à des mesures qui seront
quasiment considérées comme fasciste
pour les insoumis seront normalement
contre le projet de loi immigration
général de Darmanin
donc il ne se passera rien sur
ça
assez peu probable
Alex on regarde ce qu'elle a une de nos
cotiseurs régionaux
[Musique]
un Nord éclair Alex qui revient sur
l'accident de voiture hier matin qui a
coûté la vie à trois policiers oui un
bilan dramatique 4 personnes sont
décédées hier lors d'une collision
violente entre une voiture de police et
un autre véhicule à Villeneuve-d'Ascq
parmi elles trois jeunes policiers du
commissariat de Roubaix âgé de 24 et 25
ans sont décédés ainsi que le conducteur
de l'autre véhicule le conducteur ainsi
que le passager de l'autre véhicule qui
était connu des services de police pour
conduite sous alcool et consommation de
stupéfiants le ministre de l'Intérieur
général de Darmanin se rend ce lundi au
commissariat de Roubaix et puis une
nouvelle fusillade à Marseille la série
noire continue titre La Provence
dimanche au petit matin dans un quartier
résidentiel du 11e arrondissement de la
cité phocéenne trois jeunes ont été
abattus à l'arme de guerre l'enquête de
la police judiciaire dira si cette
fusillade s'inscrit dans la guerre que
ce livre actuellement les bandes de
narcotrafiquants depuis le mois de
janvier le bilan actuel est de 21 morts
la sécheresse
de pluie récents les réserves d'eau
restent au plus bas alors l'état de
certaines
un nappe phréatique dans certaines
régions c'est amélioré en Bretagne en
Normandie dans le grand est par exemple
mais au global et bien 68% des nappes
phréatiques du pays sont encore trop peu
remplis cet été il existe un risque
élevé de sécheresse dans 28 départements
notamment en Île-de-France en
Provence-Alpes-Côte d'Azur et en
Occitanie elle a une du Courrier Picard
une initiative intéressante de la part
de centaines de communes dans les hauts
de France elle propose une mutuelle
communale à leurs administrée pour
résoudre les problèmes d'accès aux soins
et bien ces communes signe des contrats
avec des mutuelles à des tarifs négociés
et en font ensuite bénéficier les
habitants cela représente un gain de 450
euros par an par habitant par rapport à
une mutuelle classique les étudiants les
retraités les demandeurs d'emploi sont
dans le cœur de cible de ce dispositif
on finit par du sport et on commence par
du rugby on commence par du rugby
puisque les joueurs du Stade Rochelais
sont arrivés hier à La Rochelle pour
fêter leur deuxième titre de champion
d'Europe deuxième victoire consécutive
en finale de Champions Cup c'était face
aux Irlandais du Leinster samedi le
rugby dans la peau titre le journal
Sud-Ouest une marée jaune et noire à la
une de la Charente Libre à hier le vieux
port de La Rochelle à chaviré de bonheur
un 40 000 personnes étaient présentes
pour fêter leur champion et puis en
football un nouveau titre également pour
aller jouer de l'Olympique Lyonnais qui
se sont imposés contre leur rival du PSG
hier c'est à la une du Progrès de Lyon
en 16e titre de championne de France
pour l'OL et puis chez les garçons la
course au maintien en Ligue 1 ce précise
Brest a obtenu son maintien c'est à la
une du télégram et puis c'est presque
fait pour Strasbourg après un match
nullin partout contre trois c'est elle a
une des Dernières Nouvelles d'Alsace
merci beaucoup Alex pour ce point c'est
l'Ukraine Figaro après la chute de
darkmouth sur scène va recevoir des F16
c'est une très très grosse décision en
fait c'est des F-16 européens mais il
sait c'est un avion américain mais qui
sont détenus par des États européens
mais il fallait le feu vert c'est c'est
la loi internationale en termes de vente
d'armement il faut le feu vert du pays
fabricant et donc les États-Unis ont
accepté que des pays européens libres
des F16 à l'armée ukrainienne et c'est à
dire dans le Figaro merci beaucoup Yves
stria merci à vous arrêtez avec nous
merci beaucoup merci
Alex on se retrouve demain merci à tous
de nous avoir suivis pour voir revoir
cette émission c'est sur public sena.fr
prochain rendez-vous 18h sens public et
on vous retrouve vif à 19h30 audition
publique avec le président du groupe
communiste à l'Assemblée à tout à
l'heure Yves merci à tous de nous avoir
suivis à demain
[Musique]